understanding subtraction of matrices is
very easy because it's pretty similar to
addition of matrices the rule to check
if subtraction is possible is exactly
the same as the rule for addition of
matrices two matrices can be subtracted
only if they are of the same order yes
they have to be of the same order
if not then subtraction is not possible
we'll understand this better with a
couple of examples the first matrix we
have is one for in one row and the
second matrix we have is two three in
one row is this subtraction possible I
am NOT asking you to subtract the two
matrices I am just asking you if it's
possible to subtract this matrix from
this one to know if they can be
subtracted we need to know the order of
each pause the video and find the orders
the first matrix has one row and two
columns its order will be 1 by 2 and as
the second matrix also has just one row
and two columns its order will also be 1
by 2 because the order is the same
subtraction is possible here the second
Matrix can be subtracted from the first
one but how do we subtract now if we
assume this to be a minus B we need to
subtract elements of B from the
corresponding elements of a 1 & 2 are
corresponding elements 4 & 3 are
corresponding elements what will be the
elements of the resulting matrix then
the 1 1 at element will be 1 minus 2
element of a minus the corresponding
element of B and the one 2f element will
be 4 minus 3 now we just find these two
elements to get the resulting matrix 1
minus 2 is minus 1 so we write minus 1
as the 1 1 at element 4 minus 3 is 1
which becomes the 1 to earth element
this is our answer minus 1 1
notice that the order of the resulting
matrix is also one by two the order of
the resulting matrix will always be the
same as the order of the two matrices in
question let's look at one more question
now subtract this matrix from this one
try it out to know if this matrix can be
subtracted from this one we first need
to find the orders of each the first
matrix has 2 rows and 2 columns its
order will be 2 by 2 and the second
Matrix has 2 rows and 1 column order
will be 2 by 1 the orders are not the
same which means they cannot be
subtracted so remember before performing
the operation check if they are
compatible for subtraction and only if
they have the same orders we move on to
subtracting the elements of one matrix
from the corresponding elements of the
other
[Music]